Sophia Richie officially says I do first
of all it's an awesome feeling the model
tied the knot with music exec Elliot
Grange two years after going public with
their romance great things are happening
and I'm really excited about it in the
week's leading up Sophia's prep for the
big day included documenting her
pre-wedding Pilates sessions I feel like
people get a good sense of just like fun
me and giving a glimpse inside her
lavish bridal shower
the pair got engaged last year capturing
the intimate proposal on Instagram it's
important to me that I keep it very
light-hearted Elliott popped the
question to Sophia surrounded by candles
and flower petals another shot features
a close-up look at the ring as a newly
engaged couple shares a kiss at the time
a sore throat ET the couple had been
serious for a while so their engagement
was not a big surprise to anyone I think
I grew up with a famous dad so I'm just
kind of used to the noise
yeah and her famous dad Lionel Richie
gave his stamp of approval too you know
what this is pretty fabulous family to
me is everything
ET Source says the whole film's over the
moon adding that they're really happy
for her and think Elliot's a great guy
Sophia's family's opinions have always
been something she takes to Heart
especially when it comes from Dad and
Big Sis Nicole Richie since I was really
young my both of them have always been
like you can't care what anyone has to
say about you you just have to know who
you are and I've always stuck with that
and I've always been confident with that
and she's proved that when she converted
to Judaism ahead of her in Elliot's
wedding sharing the special moment on
Instagram and calling it one of the
greatest experiences of my life do what
I want don't let people get in my head
and now after exchanging vows the two
have their whole lives ahead to create
many more great memories
[Music]
thank you